during a recent visit with former
president jimmy carter and rosalind
carter
president joe biden and his wife jill
posed for a photo
and everyone's discussing this the
bidens appear to be
huge in size look at that
yes it's stunning the photo's everywhere
everyone's talking about it
now i don't know why the bidens look so
big in the photo
so i thought i'd get them here to
explain here they are
to talk it down in person president joe
biden and first lady jill biden
oh my god hi there everyone nice to see
you
hi conan hi andy
hello everyone nice to see you
wow they really said nothing but i don't
think they had to i think that explains
it
yeah the bidens are big visual effects
provided by
tom arnold green screen the best grain
screen in the business for all your
special effects needs
tom arnold green screens yeah that's
what i'm up to now
why why
you never did anything to us yeah i bet
i bet bts knows who he is
who's this tom arnold who's that curtain
oh man who am i to make fun of tom